i'm really excited to introduce my
colleague jim scott
who is a graduate of the moores town
friends school in new jersey
as well as other fine schools he's the
author of several important books some
of which you
have probably heard of i'd call the
book's classics but unlike classics
some people actually enjoy reading jim's
books
he's a sterling professor of political
science here at yale
but we in anthropology really appreciate
it when he calls himself an
honorary anthropologist and we in the
south
southeast asian studies council really
need to thank jim for the mountains of
merit that he has
accrued on our behalf over the years in
burma like other parts of theravada
southeast asia
merit making entails the act of giving
cultivating virtue
and mental development and i think it's
suffices to say that jim does all of
those things
he's a man of many good deeds and much
merit and it's a real pleasure to
introduce him today for his talk
on irrawaddy so jim take it away
thanks a lot eric for that generous
introduction
um i want to begin actually uh
by um noticing as you
all have perhaps noticed yourselves that
we are well into our second week of the
coup
in burma military coup in burma
and there are a whole series of efforts
that are underway to provide some
international support
for the non-violent resistance in burma
uh and i'm going to have chris
put up um there there are going to be
other opportunities
uh including uh efforts to raise
subsistence funds for
all the doctors and teachers and civil
servants who were on strike
and i have contributed actually a good
part of my royalties
for the last 10 years to the assistance
association for political prisoners in
burma
it's an association of ex-prisoners that
takes care
of prisoners by sending them food
medicines taking care of their families
and taking care of them when and if
they're
released and so i think chris will put
up
um the um the easiest way to contribute
uh is via
the campaign for the rohingya um
in which the money would be forwarded to
the assistance association for political
prisoners
uh they provide by the way if you go to
their
website aappb burma
they provide a daily briefing on what's
happening in burma now
and i recommend that as a source
for day-to-day information on
the current situation in burma so thank
you
um and i'll move now to my talk if i may
um the the talk is called in praise of
floods
um the i've been teaching a seminar
on rivers uh called rivers nature
and politics for the last seven or eight
years and historically i've done
actually a fair amount of canoeing and
fishing on american
rivers and spent a long time on the
irwadi
uh in burma until the pandemic and in
fact
although i was interested in the river
itself the river was also partly an
excuse for me
that i wanted to make sure that no
matter where i was in burma
um that if the police asked what i was
doing i could say i was studying the
irawati
because i would always be close to a
tributary or a distributory of the
irrawaddy
no matter where i was in burma although
that would not hold if i were in kentung
in the sort of eastern state
but i i date the germ of this talk
actually to
an encounter i had something like 20
years ago
i found myself at a conference in which
there were hydrologists and
southeast asians to two separate
meetings going on but we were all
at the same conference site and they
wanted us to be
uh good um companions to one another so
they
ordered us at lunch and dinner to
intersperse ourselves and
carry on conversations across
disciplines and interests
and i found myself sitting next to a
very
smart and interesting philippine
hydrologist
and uh trying to be a good boy and make
conversation with him i tried to think
well what can we talk about
and i had learned in the last two or
three years before this meeting
that the colorado river never got to the
sea for
a large part of the year and um
i was sad for the colorado river it
seemed to me
all our metaphors about rivers running
to the sea
um that it it just gave me a sense of
um uh sympathy for the colorado that it
didn't get to do its thing and run to
the sea
like all rivers should and so i
i tried to start the conversation uh by
saying to the hydrologist that i had
learned this about the colorado and
wasn't it too bad that colorado didn't
get to the sea
and he turned to me very quickly and uh
with a stentorian voice and said
no no it's the most wonderful thing in
the world it means that
every drop of the colorado river is used
for some important human purpose
and not a drop goes to waste and i
realized from that moment
we were probably not going to have a
long conversation
because he was if you like right uh
a um interested in the functionality
for uh homo sapiens of the river and the
uses to which
it could be put um
he was not alone um and here
i want to quote winston churchill on the
uh nile river and i quote
one day every last drop of water which
drains
into the whole valley of the nile shall
be equally and
amicably divided among the river people
and the nile itself shall perish
gloriously and never reached the sea
uh joseph stalin who was
less given to ornamental prose uh put it
more succinctly
quote water which is allowed to enter
the sea is wasted
end quote you could have had
similar things as spoken by anyone from
the american bureau
of reclamation or the army of core of
engineers
uh until very very recently
i want to begin actually uh with a
assertion that uh everything moves
um and rivers too of course
um but it seems to me that one of the
problems
uh is that human humans are inclined to
thinking
of units of a human life um and we don't
think of
river time of mountain time of uh
tree time uh and so on uh
let alone smaller units like insect time
you might
uh say but if you open the temporal lens
wide enough everything moves
and uh my illustration
of this um let's see if this works
there we go
this is a 120 000
year video of the movement
of the polar ice cap
you can see it moving
and the how many thousand years ago is
up
in the upper left-hand corner you will
see that 17 or 18 000 years ago
was the last glacial maximum
after which uh the ice the polar cap
retreats and continues retreating today
of course
but you see the enormous right variation
over time
rivers like the st lawrence seaway were
essentially the breaking up of a glacial
lake called lake agassi
um right after the last glacial maximum
so now that's the last glacial maximum
and then there's the retreat
the picture i would have preferred to
show you although i couldn't get an
animation of it is that after the last
glacial maximum
we think of trees for example as being
static and being and
not moving but in fact they're moving
all the time and
it's again opening the temporal lens so
if you were to have a time elapsed
photograph
after uh the last glacial maximum you
would see
century by century the oaks and the
beaches
moving north from the mediterranean um
as the climate improved and things got
warmer uh
and so the trees would be moving and
bringing together with them
their soils the insects the animals and
so on
uh that are part of the uh
larger ecosystem of boreal forests
i want to next move to
there we go these are actually prepared
by the army corps of engineers this is
about a thousand-year
depiction of the different bends and
channels
of the mississippi river the white
portion
um is the current um
channel of the mississippi river but you
get some sense
for where the mississippi has been and
some sense for
where it might go were it not chained
this is another version of the river i
think near st
louis if i'm not mistaken um
the uh an other example that's uh quite
famous
is the yellow river uh estuary
there are major shifts north and south
of the shandong peninsula
from 20 uh 2200 bc
um and the second slide
shows shifts in the major distributors
distributors of the yellow river in the
last two centuries
alone it's a huge
variation and in fact the second to last
um movement of the major channel
of the yellow river to the sea um
was in 1938 when chiang kai-shek
broke the dikes of the yellow river in
order to send it south
in order to impede the japanese advance
to the north it was successful but it
cost something like
um 300 000 lives
the process of this change has
all to do with the gradient of the
coastal plain that is to say
if the gradient is very low
the river slows down and as it slows the
sediment it carries
settles out and raises the riverbed
over time it's self-damming that is to
say
it creates its own levy ahead of it
and then it spreads laterally and seeks
another path to the sea
as a new channel is clogged over time
the river may go back to an older
channel
that is now a faster way to the sea the
process is natural
though the amount of sediment can vastly
be increased of course by
deforestation in the watershed and of
course the river is likely to build
new land in the estuary itself
each flood raises the land flooded by
the deposition of sediment
so that the floodplain of the middle
nile for example is now
10 feet higher than it was 5 000 years
ago
george perkins marsh actually understood
all of this in his
magnificent book man and nature
published in 1864
thus riverport towns and coastal towns
at a river's mouth are vulnerable to
being blocked
by the buildup of silt and sand the most
famous example of this i think is bruges
the great linen center
uh its river the artery uh and and the
artery that
made it bruges as a linen center was the
zwin
river it silted up in the 15th century
and the merchants left
for antwerp leaving this urban 16th
century gem
as a kind of museum piece that we can
admire today on the upper rhine for
example brizak
in roman times was on the left bank and
the in the
in the 10th century it was on an island
in the 13th century on the left bank
again
and in the 14th century up till today it
was
on the right bank um so
this movement is constant uh over time
and in my personal experience we have a
summer cabin in central pennsylvania
um which we would go to every summer for
the better part of a decade with the
children and
i observed each year the
what's called the accretion or carving
out by the ice in the spring
of each meander and had the sense for
the slow
change in the course of the river
uh but i was misled by this gradual
change because
in 1972 there was a huge flood
i realized that 99 of the change in this
creek
came during the high water of this
massive flood two or three hours
right in 1972 that cut off meanders
leaving oxbows and so on um and that
this is called an international law
avulsion rather than
accretion and that most of the great
changes in the river
are these catastrophic events of massive
uh high water moments um
i want to show
this is the process of creating oxbows
this is an oxbow that has been recently
cut off as you can see
and the next flood you can see an oxbow
that whose
uh lifetime is limited probably
uh to the next great flood because that
that loop
to your left will be cut off uh as well
i'm going to leave up
um which its major tributaries
uh to the north are the malika and maika
uh that join the to create
the irrawaddy uh north of michigan
uh that then flows south to mandalay
it's joined by the chinwin right uh and
if i had a map of the urwati over time
um it's been changed radically
it's channeled by volcanic uh events
the sit-down river was in fact the
channel of the irawati to the sea uh
in geological times and after the
eruption of mount pulpa
and so on uh the bed of the irwadi
was changed quite radically
the erawadi is moving all the time
uh and i want to give you a sense of
this uh
on one trip downstream from mandalay to
the ancient capital of pagan
it was a day a day's trip
um a small inboard motorboat carrying
no more than 20 passengers
what was interesting to me is that we
used
four pilots whom we picked up along the
way
and each of these pilots was an expert
in a section of the river
and essentially a two-hour sail
down the river and after
their knowledge ran out they would get
off
and we would take on another pilot who
was an expert for the next little patch
of the river
because this and these people had worked
at these jobs
for 20 30 years so the captain of the
boat who'd been
going up and down the irwadi for a long
long time he did not trust himself
to understand the different shifts um
in the sandbanks and channel day by day
and week by week
without using these pilots and still
uh in this case we didn't get stuck but
in many cases
even with these pilots it's not very
uncommon
to be to be stuck and the larger
cargo carriers especially during low
water
in february and march the danger
was much greater and there are many of
the larger cargo carriers
that are irretrievably stuck and have to
wait until the monsoon season
in order to be floated off uh the
uh the mud banks or sandbanks in which
they're
um embedded
um the
next i want to show um this
is a common sight on some of the larger
passenger boats
and you see that long bamboo pole and it
is a depth gauge there are two of them
usually at the um
at the prowl um of
each boat and uh when they are
in shallow waters there are two people
shouting out
um the depth of the river from both
sides of the boat actually
um and it's they're yelling
more than five feet less than four feet
etc etc
uh and this is exactly kind of mark
twain's point on life in the mississippi
marking on the twine
right is the uh equivalent of the
mississippi
riverboats that had to do precisely the
same thing
and still it was very common for
stuck you may wonder what these people
are doing in the water
first of all notice how shallow it is
right um
this passenger uh boat has
become stuck and what they've done is to
send
uh two or three members of the crew out
and they
have a stake another close-up
they have a stake which they embed
in the sand of the river they will then
attach that to a cable which will then
be attached to a winch at the back of
the boat that will
winch it will winch it in and winch it
out
and the idea is to wiggle uh the prowl
of the boat
until it can be backed off the
bank in which it's embedded the engines
are of course going in reverse
uh but the winching is necessary in
order to
uh unembed it and that's why actually
the ships going downstream in low water
have the right of way because if you get
stuck
going downstream the current is your
enemy because it embeds you deeper
and it's harder to back off uh whereas
the ships going
upstream don't have the right-of-way
because
it's much easier for them to get off
um
the variation over time one more thing
about rivers as
living things um it
helps to tell us that
ideas such as the 100-year flood or
50-year flood that you hear
all the time in weather reports and
disaster reports
is and i choose my words carefully
nonsense um that is to say
um the for example the rhine
had four 100 year floods in 12 years
in 1983 88 93 and 94.
that should give one some pause over the
meaning of a hundred year flood
why but for most rivers
not quite all of them we simply don't
have the statistical series on water
levels
and volume flows that go back more than
100 200 years
which would even in principle allow us
to make
such a statistical generalization now
the yellow river or the yangza or the
rhine or danube or euphrates
are partial exceptions to this and we
have a longer statistical series
but more important even if we did have a
deep series
the assumption behind the hundred year
flood and the 50-year flood
is the assumption of hydrological
equilibrium
but it's not the same river from year to
year
it's moving silt and sand and clay
it's carving new channels and meanders
its normal flood stage is building
natural levees
and if we add anthropogenic changes in
particular
it's radically not the same river
that is to say in 1800 most of the
mississippi
bank was forested but by 1960
95 was planted to agricultural crops
forget about all the other interventions
which are made
into the river now i want to talk
my my problem in my seminar with
students
in on rivers uh was that
um they're mostly interested in actually
like the philippine hydrologist i
mentioned
they're interested in the uses of the
river for homo sapiens for
drinking water for irrigation
um etc uh flood control
and um i hope when i write the book
about the irwati because i have a lot of
data
on fish migrations uh and so on
uh and migrations of birds and uh
riverine mammals
as well uh to talk more about all those
creatures that depend
on the river for their life world
including
uh clams and mussels shellfish and
larvae
the most important movement in the
annual life
of the river is what is called the flood
pulse
it's a very i think important choice of
terms
that is to say that part of the year
during which the river overflows
its natural channel and occupies its
habitual floodplain the pulse
of high water may come from the monsoon
from snow or glacial melt or from
seasonal rainfall
and it may be of different degrees of
variability but it is
a completely natural part of the annual
cycle of a river the flooding of the
floodplain represents the lungs
of a river in a literal sense that is to
say the condition of its vitality
and its nutrition and that of the
creatures who depend on it
the annual flooding of the floodplain
the channel which we usually associate
with the river at rest
in our paintings and photographs is
comparatively dead
biotically speaking flood as a scare
word is so deeply anthropogenic
that i want to ban its use but it's not
in my power alas
it's just the river breathing as it must
on this view we would understand a
flooding of settlements near the river
as a result of homo sapiens encroaching
on the natural plain of the river that
is to say
an act of trespass
the periodic flooding of the floodplain
is the life world and condition of
existence
of all of the species that inhabit the
river
or who dwell along the river and here
this is not
uh this is an
effort um by a disturbance ecologist to
show you
uh the uh how the level of a river
over time uh brings nutrients
to higher and higher ground uh and then
and then retreats
fish for example get as much as 80 of
their total annual nutrition from the
huge pulse of food
that the flood stage affords as they
spread out over the floodplain
there they spawn and put on weight they
feed on the invertebrates
decaying organic matter the microbes
that are on the floodplain
there's almost always a huge migration
of fish to take advantage of this
feeding
frenzy uh anadromous fish that uh
come in from the sea for that matter uh
are there in partly
in in large part for this sea pulse
event
the floodplain may be 40 times wider
than the channel
in places like the amazon where there's
a huge variation
you have fruit eating fish for the
simple reason
that the water level gets so high that
the fish
can uh profit from what we call the
low-hanging fruit
that are on the adjacent uh banks
the mississippi fish catch had declined
more than 80 percent uh in the years up
to
1993 but the result of the 1993 massive
flood
was that the fish catch in the year
afterwards
was a new record and the year after that
also a new record because of the
spawning
and greater population of fish the
studies of the danube have shown that
the greater the extent of the flood in a
given year
the greater the hall of fish by the way
it's not just fish of course
but a whole cavalcade of all those
creatures that depend
on a concentration of nutrition
waterfowl who were there because the
birds are there in the
along the air body the way in which
fishermen
can tell that there's a migration of
fish coming
is that the birds appear before
the fish migrate because they've in a
sense learned further downstream that
the fish are on the way
and they precede the fish and wait for
their
feast and the fishermen then know
it's time to get out the nets and get
ready for uh the migration
of fish um waterfowl
and riverine wetland birds um in the
west
heron muskrats fox wolves raptors
herbivores
come we come for the fresh grouse excuse
me fresh grass
sprouting after the flood recedes and
all the micro parasites that feed
on this cavalcade and then as the flood
recedes
much of this nutrition returns to the
channel
where some of the larger fish channel
cats and dolphins
can benefit from it as well as the
comparatively immobile
shellfish clams and bottom larvae that
is to say
the flood pulse brings back to the
channel
nutrition that it would not otherwise
have
that it collects if you like from the
floodplain
so what the flood does in one sense is
to provide connectivity
it moves water over the landscape
creating a huge variety of habitats
backwaters ponds marsh environments slow
moving water
a warmer water refugees refuges
from larger predators varied assemblages
of food and habitat
that favor different riverine species
the whole mechanism depends on the
microbial richness of the floodplain
that represents the base of the food
pyramid
and the entire life world of the river
without the flood pulse then the river
is comparatively dead
i mean to emphasize non-human species
here
but let me say a bit about the fl what
the flood pulse
does for homo sapiens the most
numerous and most successful invasive
species
the world has known well
what it does is civilization
no floodplain no civilization that's
something of a slight exaggeration but
not
great not a great exaggeration
almost without exception all archaic
civilizations were founded on
floodplains
often near the estuary of a river why
that's the only place where you can have
a concentration of foodstuffs
and people in a small circumference
in which state making is possible
observe what the flood does it drowns
all the competing vegetation aka weeds
it lays down a layer of nutritious silt
that provides nutrients to the crops
usually cereal grains it provides if
it's well
behaved as the nile valley generally is
a perfectly harrowed field ready for
sowing
no plowing needed just broadcast to
seeds
in a sense the flood does the
agricultural work except for the sowing
and the harvesting
in the same way by the way if you the
comparable case for um inland
agriculture in the hills is shifting or
fire field cultivation or slash and burn
cultivation
in which the job of uh that water does
in uh what i call flood recession
agriculture uh what the job that fire
does
is exactly the what water does in flood
recession agriculture that is to say
uh it burns uh this thing organic matter
provides um uh fertilizer
and all the fields have to be moved from
time to time
uh it's essentially the same uh process
um
the um hence the oldest
form of agriculture was
it's called flood recession agriculture
or in french
de cru um it uh
it's also common in eastern woodland
uh agriculture in among native americans
these would be the places along streams
that were
annually flooded that would be the
places where
native americans would do uh early
uh planting
i'll make sure i've got the there we go
um
this is a um
an island uh in the upper
uh erawadi and it is a
completely flood recession agriculture
um and it is
something like um
five or six hundred uh acres
um that is recreated every year
and that six villages share or fight
about i should say
uh in terms of who gets what because uh
this
uh patch is changing every year
depending on the accumulation
of silt uh and soil but it's a
major agricultural site and there is a
bamboo bridge rebuilt nearly two miles
long
built every year in order that people
can get
from one bank to this island uh
in in the middle and in the
delta the irrawaddy delta um
there are hundreds and hundreds of uh
such islands with complicated forms
of property rights uh with efforts to
shore up property rights by
driving in bamboo stakes and making sure
that
the new silt accumulates on their side
of the island
rather than on another side of the
island so it's a whole world
in which our sense of if you like land
staying in place uh doesn't hold
and it is a if you like shifting flood
plains
uh that are in the middle of a river or
offshore from its uh its banks
the west way best way of understanding
this is through
what is often called disturbance ecology
i don't like the term disturbance
because it risks obscuring the fact
that floods are often annual natural and
fairly predictable
that is to say they're not disturbances
at all
or such disturbances are normal cyclical
but it is proposed in contrast
distinction
to equilibrium analysis in which the
succession and distribution of fish and
insects and birds
reached a terminal state that was stable
as we shall see it's the prevention
or the forceful stopping of these
natural perturbations
that is the real disturbance the real
intervention
the attempt to enforce a permanent
equilibrium natural disturbances create
new mosaics of plants and animals
insects they open the canopy they
destroy
or displace many species but they begin
a new succession of colonists
the result is more biodiversity in terms
of a variety of species
and this mosaic of patches that is in
turn
more resilient it's worth recalling what
the flood
accomplishes it eliminates much previous
vegetation it soaks the soil differently
uh it brings in nutritious
silt uh and it is an
open and inviting environment waiting to
be colonized
by flood adapted marine life by flood
adapted insect life by flood adapted
flora
seeds that have been waiting for a long
long time
quick colonizing species from adjacent
patches
a slower colonization from further away
it's a favorable spawning environment
for
a selection of fish insects and birds
who do best in uncrowded open
environments
it creates then innumerable edge
environments or ecotones that are as we
know
species rich because they provide access
to two or more environments sometimes
seasonal
this is what happens without humans
humans can use and shape this process so
along the nile
just poking a hole in the natural levees
of the river
at a flood stage could inundate the back
slopes and hollows with silt rich water
and then when the water had soaked in
one could plant
wheat or barley and no state was needed
so the uh if you like
the agriculture along the nile river was
a completely village affair
had nothing to do with pharaohs and
state-like entities
creating irrigation flood recession
agriculture
is simplest it just uses nature to
work with a little nudge
now um how am i doing in terms of time
uh eric five minutes jim you have a
little bit more than
five minutes is good i'm sorry i gotta
put on my
yeah you have five five minutes
okay good uh
what we've done with rivers is to
simplification
simplify them by engineering
humankind has of course been sculpting
rivers for its purposes forever
but only with the invention of dynamite
in 1870
and subsequent earth-moving machinery
and reinforced concrete
has this sculpting taking on protein
proportions
as you know one of the interesting
things about the ear water is that
the earwadi does not have any dams on
its main stem
the effort to build a dam at the uh
zone at the origin of the irwadi which
was underway
actually and was stopped by
actually a democratic movement and a
general's compliance with that
democratic movement
there are lots of dams north of
the origin of the irwadi on the
tributaries that contribute to the
irwadi
and they've had a huge effect on the
hydrology of the irwadi but the irwadi
itself
is so far an undammed uh
undammed river
the engineering of rivers is
i like to think of it as some
combination of taxidermy and amputation
because the simplification of the effort
of these interventions is usually to
simplify the river
and to have it serve a single functional
purpose
the rhine is this striking example
johann got three tula around 1800
responsible for a treaty called the
rectification of the rhine among the
all the adjacent rhine nations
the wonderful word rectification of the
rhine is a is a wonderful term as if god
had somehow
if you'll excuse the expression [ __ ]
up and that the rhine had to be
rectified from
its original um form
the it was an actual treaty it
eliminated meanders removed barriers in
the channel
it confined the river to a single bed
with no braids
to a uniform width where possible
through a uniform depth
and a uniform speed of current that is
to say
the effort was to turn the rhine into a
canal
so far as was possible predictable
uniform straight obeying bernoulli's
principle of pressure
and turbulence to take a variable and
turn it into a constant
the rhine was shortened by 105
kilometers and it lost 80 percent
of its floodplain in the
upper rhine
i'm going to go through
skip some things
i i should add
hang on
there's the rhine and you can see the
old rhine and
the new reformed uh rhine uh
as it was uh shortened over time
the section that i skipped over by the
way
is a section on the way in which
people run away running away from states
have run to marshes and wetlands
because they're extremely hard to police
whether it's the marsh arabs
whether it's the great dismal swamp that
held
more than 6 000 runaway slaves at the
beginning of the civil war
uh marshes and swamps have been and
if you like refugees uh refuges
over time for
people wanting to evade the state for
one reason or another
the the result of the rectification of
the rhyme
is that a drop of water that falls in
switzerland now
takes only three days to get to holland
whereas before it took something like 10
days
the results of this for catastrophic
floods and high water
are something that you can appreciate
and the degree to which
a big rainfall is quickly channeled into
the river
uh because of the changes of its banks
and the changes in the channel george
perkins marsh understood this
as a simple matter of physics say a
river has
sixteen hundred a sixteen hundred mile
course
say the natural channel drops eight
hundred feet from the origin to the sea
that's a drop of six inches to the mile
by shortening the river and cutting off
meanders let's say you make it only 12
100 miles long then the pitch is
increased
to eight inches to the mile
it's only two inches it's one quarter
steeper but it has tremendous effects on
the speed on how much silt it carries
on the height of probable flood crests
on the erosion of banks and if you then
try to minimize floods by preventing
lateral movement
of river water by levees you increase
the amount of silt
carried to the mouth the silting up of
the dutch estuary
is a good example as aldo leopold
once wrote the germans had a fondness
for unnecessary
outdoor geometry other simplifications
are hydroelectric dams and irrigation
which create chains of lakes
still water which destroys fish
migrations in both directions
and prevents the natural conveyor belt
of silt
river prevents the natural
movement of a river it raises the
question
of when is a river still a river
how many things can you do to a river
and still call it a river
i i once had a colleague in wisconsin
who had a cat and since i was in
wisconsin for the
better part of a decade i i would visit
them
this family often i will not name them
and the cat
uh somehow that its tail had been docked
for some reason
um it had been neutered uh
and shortly in the year before i left
since it was tearing up the furniture
it had been declawed and my wife and i
um on the way back uh from this visit
wondered to one another how many things
could you take away from a cat and still
have a cat
and somehow the the declawing of a cat
seemed somehow to be
over the over the red line but i think
it's worth saying
what happens in the engineering of river
uh which is never completely successful
by the way
when you try to turn it into a canal
a pipe a
a chain of lakes that can be used for
irrigation uh
and so on um i want to
one of the results of
this effort to control a river
um this is the yellow river near
kaifeng and because of the use of levees
over time
it's a rich agricultural area and as the
river carried more silt and therefore
the bed of the river
got higher and higher and higher in
order to
prevent catastrophic floods the levees
were built higher and higher and higher
over time so that now at kaifeng uh
at least when this book was this book
was written from which the image was
taken
the river was uh 33 feet
above the surrounding flood plain
so you may want to call that a river
but to me it looks a lot more like an
aqueduct
uh and it's an aqueduct that's been made
by the engineering of the river that
gradually increased its um
uh its bed the height of its bed
and necessitated if you wanted to
uh protect the farmland around it who
were taxpaying farmers and so on
uh then you built the levees higher and
higher and higher
and it set the stage for catastrophic
floods
um so when a flood then does occur
it's likely to be a massive and enormous
flood
i don't want to wind up here and i it
this
requires me to vastly shorten
the last part of the talk but i'll try
to summarize it briefly
there's something in medicine called
iatrogenic illnesses
uh which are a fancy term for the cure
being worse than the disease
um it the super bugs that one finds in
hospitals
that in a sense by trying to stop small
infections with antibiotics
you create the selection pressures that
increase over time
the bacteria that are able to survive
these
uh insults and
poisons and still survive and then you
create superbugs that thrive in
hospitals and so on
um i won't go into this but iatrogenic
medicine
is extremely important a tremendous
number of the hospitalizations that
occur
are in a sense the result of treatment
uh rather than um
the illness itself so the treatment so
i want to argue that the
um the effort to prevent small
infections
results in large infections the result
to prevent small floods and there you
have political lock-in because
representatives want to preserve the
population because they're paying taxes
because they vote for them
and will do anything they can to
preserve the
real estate values um you get this
political lock-in
uh as well and the result is
then a uh and it's
here forest fires are a good analogy the
effort
for 60 years by the forest service to
prevent all
fires resulted in catastrophic fires
because of the buildup
of combustible materials right and the
prevention
of natural fires and in the same way uh
there's an iatrogenic process in which
the effort to present
prevent small floods um uh
has resulted in large floods the 1993
uh flood of the mississippi and missouri
is a good example
and now the most the smallest
most hesitant and timid efforts are
being made
to restore flood plains um
and wetlands that have been destroyed
but to an extent that is so
trivial and timid that um it has not
made much of a dent
in the if you like the death of rivers
or the maiming of rivers
or the taxidermy of rivers uh
that we experience let me stop there
happy to take any questions
thank you jim for that fascinating talk
let's take a moment
um and and thank jim for the talk um
if you want to take a moment to clap so
i don't mistake your clapping for your
raised hands um i'll take a moment
so what we'll do here is if you can
raise your hand
using the hand raise function of
zoom please do that if you can't figure
out how to do that
send a text to me via the chat
um and if you can't figure out how to do
that wave your hand wildly on the screen
and hopefully i'll see it eventually
and i'll keep track of it the first hand
that was up was paul sarno
after that it will be michael dove and
then i'll type a list
of the order in the chat um so let's
start with paul
and and please keep your um questions
relatively brief if you don't mind
because i'm sure there's going to be a
lot of
questions to on the table so thank you
hi jim thank you very much i i have a
layman's question it it sounds like from
what you're
saying it's not a good idea to dam up
rivers and if that's true does that mean
the major reason one of the range of
reasons i thought for damning up the
river is you can get a lot of hydro
power and if that was relatively clean
energy am i correct in those
suppositions that it's not a good idea
to dam up rivers are not a good idea to
dam up even tributaries
well if if you're if you're focused on
how much power you can generate
relatively cleanly for homo sapiens the
answer
is you're right if you're
interested in the life world of the
river
and the migrating fish
and the life forms that depend on the
natural processes of the river
uh and of its floods and so on
then for them it's almost certain death
um and so it depends whether
that's the point it depends whether
you're focusing you know i suppose
wind and solar are rather better than
hydroelectric and there are
by the way small dams
uh run of the river dams i mean there
it's
you know there's a topology of dams um
in which um uh which are more or less
destructive
uh as dams in terms of the natural
processes of the river
so the world commission on dams actually
has a set of principles that it
established this is after the narmada
dam protests um uh for
dams that are well okay
uh if not you know uh uh
entirely approved
thanks jim thanks paul for that question
um michael
uh thanks eric um this was fascinating
jim i i was interested
in your likening of the impacts of
flooding
to to the impacts of fire in the hills
so this this gives us two pulses to
compare
a pulse from wet to dry to wet
and in the hills a pulse from field
to forest back to field so two different
pulses
and it seems like these
these pulses have been
problematic for land tenure at least the
way
outsiders view land tenure so i'm
wondering
if you can place the 10 uriel
implications of these pulses
in the longer history of of
of land tenure for fixed land
within which these seem to be as i said
problematic
i'm thinking um
the uh
i suppose uh maybe this is what you're
implying um in your comments
um i was interested in the nutrient
cycle of silk versus you know
fire and the way in which it provided
the
basis for cropping uh but you raised the
question which is
even more interesting in many ways uh
which
is the our our idea of
property that is based on
um fixed borders uh
and fixed tenure and titles when
uh in fact in the
flood recession agriculture that i'm
talking about
the land is shifting all the time uh
under
the pressure of floods and the
deposition of silt and sand
and gravel and
for slash and burn agriculture
uh shifting agriculture
it requires that in a sense the
fields be moved but it it's within
as you know a lot better than i do
uh it's within a fixed
compass uh by and large uh or
if you like a rotation of following um
and uh the it's
as again what's interesting is in terms
of customary land tenure
the people who are not planning a
particular sweden are likely to
have recognized rights to
the things that are popping up in the
sweden anyway
and the right to return to it is that
correct
yes
i'm not sure i answered your question
michael i i would like to hear a lecture
from you on the comparison
that was great thanks jim i think we can
have a special workshop on this topic
with michael and jim meeting head to
head uh we have a question from jacob
uh hi uh scott that was uh really
interesting i i really
uh uh appreciated hearing about um all
the river meandering
issues which is something that's
certainly been on my mind
uh recently i guess i'm gonna keep my
question
short as requested i'm wondering about
the implications
of a world of re-liberated rivers where
they're permitted to meander they're
permitted to be dynamic and they're
permitted to have their flood cycles
the implications for um human
settlement urbanization town and city
location patterns implications for
transportation
i'm struck by your example of the
temporary seasonal bamboo bridge i've
seen bridges like that
in a room intervertex in india
at a particular river location where
during sometimes in the year you get
across
on a ferry boat and in other times of
year you have to use an elephant to wade
across
the elephants swim in the deep part of
the channel with people on its back
and then in another time of year when
it's appropriate you have this temporary
bridge
and that's really neat at that
particular location it's a village
called dambuc
but if we're talking about re-liberating
the entire lower rhine or the entire
lower mississippi
um what happens to town and
uh city settlements what happens to road
infrastructure how do people get from
point a to point b
um if even even if uh if rivers are
constantly meandering then that means
that sand bars are constantly being
rearranged so even things like uh
having regular fairy roots might be
difficult so i'm wondering how could you
kind of um
reintegrate those kinds of human needs
with these with re-liberated rivers
it's a great question and um
my my job is to diagnose where we are
not how we get out of it
um the um and so i don't have
uh a lot what's what's interesting to me
for example
is that there were um
this is actually covered kind of
brilliantly in mark elvin's the retreat
of the elephants
since you mentioned elephants um the
difference between
the confu there were there were
traditionally in china
um river masters
and there were two schools of river
mastery
a confusion school and a daoist school
and the confucian school was sort of
like the army corps of engineers more or
less
let's make the river do what we wanted
to do
and the uh the taoist school
was to try to work within
the limits of the rivers natural
movements so they would have for example
gates or sluices that would be over
spills loses that would only open when
the pressure of the water reached a
certain
level naturally without any human
intervention
they were engineered that way um the
uh the other example that is an
accommodation
i think it's above st louis on the
mississippi river
uh in which a whole series of areas
were um uh recently developed and were
destroyed something like
two or three times in a course of 20
years
and the result was actually to
forbid rebuilding in those areas
first of all it was hard to get
insurance for them as you might imagine
the third time around and
the result was that you had this land
was
actually very good agricultural land and
very good for
sports field land
it just couldn't have permanent
structures on it
so most of the year was perfectly usable
but it was unoccupied and a potential
flood plain
in those areas where uh when the river
uh rose so it was a if you like an
overspill
and it ended up protecting
um downriver settlements that were um uh
otherwise in danger uh if there were not
this over spill area
there's there's a history by the way um
uh of uh
struggle between
settlements on opposite sides of a river
that's in flood stage
uh of who's going to break the dikes on
which side
and so there there's a whole japanese
literature on
uh people rolling over from one village
to break the dikes on their competing
settlement on the other side of the
river so that it releases the pressure
on them
um and uh there's a
uh in a sense there's uh uh
there i think are a series of
accommodations the problem the reason
why i don't think it has a solution
in your terms is because of political
lock-in
uh that you have if you like a whole
series of
investment uh population congressional
districts
industries and so on that are built on
the floodplain
and that can in a sense
mandate the public expenditure in order
to protect them
and also lobby the government for
uh reduced insurance rates in order to
protect them with the result of course
that you have you set yourself up for
larger disasters over time i think
thank you thanks jim and thanks uh jacob
for that question
um now we have a question from ian baird
who's probably he's coming in from
madison probably defending the cats of
madison as well as having a question
well i i i won't think i won't make any
comments about the cats but um
i will say that that was a great talk
and uh thank you so much for that i just
wanted to add
one uh aspect to to what you presented
which relates this i idea of energy
so and when i talk about energy i'm not
talking about electricity that's
produced
or energy that's you know given to human
use
i'm talking about the energy of the
river when it flows downstream
and one of the things that happens in
the irrawaddy and also in the mekong
where i work
is um when fish migrate upstream
um many of them migrate upstream and
then they they spawn
upstream and then it coincides with the
increasing of the
of the uh of the of the monsoon rains
and the increasing of the size of the
river
and the energy of the river actually uh
helps those small larvae that are that
are that are born
to to flow down the river you know um
and one of the the the huge impacts of
hydropower dams big dams
is actually they stop the energy what
they do is they
you think the dams produce energy well
they do but they stop the energy in the
sense that they
often create reservoirs and so those
fish
or larvae that are flowing downstream
all of a sudden reach the
the reservoir and then the the the
speed slows down and these larvae kind
of drop
out and often get trapped in the
reservoir and even if they could make it
through the turbines
further downstream they don't because of
the disruption of the
energy flow of the river itself
or the life pulse if you might put it
that way
so i think that that's just another way
of i think adding to what's
already a great uh presentation of the
ecological aspects and how
they're very much related i mean the
mekong itself has the
the largest freshwater fishery in the
world and
you know this disruption of flow and
you know similarly with the iwati uh if
they were to build the dam on the
mainstream
or even on many tributaries for that
matter you know has really a devastating
impact
right i'm actually i want to
start by saying i've learned a lot about
the mekong and about
rivers from reading your some of your
work on the mekong
the i think it's not appreciated
we we're very much aware these days
of 4 000 mile migrations by birds
uh annually right uh and the importance
of these flyways and so on
and i think we don't realize uh
the extraordinary distances of
anadromous and um i forgot
the
the antonym is for that um that
the fish that that breed in fresh water
and go to salt water
and right hydra's right
um that what that we don't the
extent of migrations is
of distances that are astounding just as
astounding as they are
for birds of four five six seven
thousand
uh miles i mean the the movement of
eels for example in the pacific uh and
so on
and so when you it's as if
you somehow had a barrier that destroyed
the flyway for bird migrations
every time you put in a dam not only
is this still water much less nutritious
and much less biotically alive than
moving water
but you also prevent the movement
and nutrition and in a sense the life
world
this is their medium right uh they
for them the river is their life world
and that's why
um you know we may
not want to sacrifice uh the last ounce
of kilowatts that we can get from uh a
dam
um but uh there are other ways we can
get
most much of our power without
destroying the life world of a
whole spectrum of species that depend on
it and
who knows what their effects are in the
long run
if they're lost
thanks jim um so we have a few more
minutes and we have several more
questions
um i want to ask jim do you mind uh
continuing to answer questions for
another eight minutes or so sure of
course
okay so the next question from john
seidel
after john is michael van gaal
just i mean after john will be michael
vann then
um alan popkin jamie anderson
and hans steinmueller so you can see
there's a fair number of questions um
let's let's have john ask his and then
we'll see how far we get in that list
uh hi jim nice to see you you're the the
last person i've had an
indoor meal with uh other than my family
on march on march 16th or something
yeah exactly um brilliant talk
uh wonderfully to get a sense of the the
forthcoming book
and one thing i was struck by was the
sort of characteristic reference to a
variety of
different rivers and
commonalities across them but i guess my
question is whether
there reaches a point in human history
recent history where we find that what
happens in one river
happens in other rivers not only
simultaneously
more or less but in an interconnected
fashion
so for example we know from mark elvin
what happens
to the pearl river delta
with silk cultivation
but then that has knock-on effects in
terms of stimulating
demand for rice
from elsewhere so this then impacts on
the mekong
arguably maybe in the red river delta as
well and it could even be that if you go
back to the conditions that
uh that stimulate french demand for
chinese silk that they come from
things that happened in rivers you know
the loire the rhone
in france who knows it might be there
i'm not sure but in other words
does there come a point where what
happens in one river
you know happens in all rivers or that
that interconnectedness with steamboats
and otherwise
takes on a kind of uh catalytic effect
a kind of multiplier effect that so you
can't study one river without running
into
the impact of other rivers the histories
are intertwined
as it were
i'm um that's a rich question and could
could go in many different directions in
terms of
um talking about it the
it seems to me it's actually it's useful
actually to um
once you get uh steam power
and you get these enormous sort of
barges
um that can carry huge
bulk goods on on navigable rivers like
the mississippi and the rhine and so on
that's what
and they're designed and engineered and
transformed for exactly
that purpose they they they carry
bulk goods especially they're they are
superior to any other form of
transportation where that's available
for all goods that have a relatively low
uh value per unit weight and volume
so that for example that's why the mrs
lower mississippi is
the cotton cultivation right and its
consequences the
shipping of grain um and of course
gravel and stone and charcoal and
timber etc um and so
somehow it seems to me that that both
the
um invention of steam power
and the capacity to move an enormous
amount
of cargo um with relatively little
friction because that's what the river
provides is important um but i also
uh it seems to me that our our capacity
to change the rivers that's why i
went out of my way to emphasize dynamite
and
reinforce concrete uh and earth-moving
machinery
uh because our capacity
to make rivers do what we want them to
do
in order to serve as
vehicles commerce and transportation are
dependent
on those late 19th century and early
20th century
and let me let me also add um
uh ian would know this and many of you
would know this from
uh work on asia that in fact
and it's not just the chinese but it's
especially the chinese
there is a dan industrial complex
in which having damned every river in
china
all of these engineers and the capital
are looking to build dams in southeast
asia
in africa just the way the italians
and norwegians want to build tunnels
everywhere in the world
um so there is a if you like there's a
um an enormous emphasis because you can
prove
uh certain benefits and there we could
go into the
cost-benefit analysis that is so bogus
with respect to
the uh the uh organizat
the rationale for dams in terms of their
economic
uh benefits um but it seems to me that
there is if you like a kind of
international combine of engineers
major corporations state and non-state
corporations
for whom river engineering is
their business and they have an enormous
amount of influence
uh it provides jobs benefits capital
um and so on and so that shouldn't be
overlooked i don't think
thanks jim uh now we have a question
from michael van
hi um thank you so much for the great
talk professor scott a big fan of your
work
also thank you to yale for making this
public this is really the zoom
or the the cove and silver lining for a
lot of us is zoom talks
um just a real quick question if the
answer is no
move on to the next question but if it's
yes um
i'd like to hear a little more do you
find in your
analysis of the rivers the term
anthropocene useful
for categorizing historical development
if not fine but
if yes how um what does the study of
rivers
tell us about uh conceptualizing the
anthropocene
uh unfortunately uh
the answer is yes uh that is to say now
i have to elaborate don't i
um the uh
well
if one of the ways in which i understand
this
is to take um
george perkins marsha's book from 1864.
uh and so he's operating at a time
before at least the real growth of steam
power
um and he understands the way in which
deforestation and so on so they're it's
not as if they're
it's it's what i would describe as a a
lighter uh thin anthropocene
that he's describing in the way in which
we've changed uh
rivers and it seems to me that uh
because of the technological uh
innovations that
i mentioned the dynamite of reinforced
concrete etc
uh is that our capacity to
intervene and reshape the landscape and
the and the hydrology of rivers
uh has grown at an exponential rate uh
and that as a a result it's become
an important political resource for lots
of
uh states i think who know the uh
the burmese military right as a
specialist at building roads and dams
and bridges basically that's all it does
as near as i can tell
um it's like an engineering military
regime uh it's the as if the army corps
of engineers took over the
united states um but it seems to me that
uh yes i mean we can't uh
it's hard to understand um
what's happened to rivers without these
anthropogenic
interventions and the fact
which i think is often overlooked is
that
in 1750 there were only three quarters
of a billion of us
and now we're going on eight billion uh
so it's not as if you know the
uh uh anthropos
right anthropods that are screwing up
the planet
are uh uh eight times more numerous than
they were more than eight times more
numerous than they were
uh in 1750. so that all by itself
um is an enormous burden
on the resources that a river can
provide
thanks um given the time i'm going to
ask if
alan potkin jamie anderson and hans
steinmueller
might ask their questions together
so that we can kind of see if there's a
thread
linking them together i'm sorry to do
that to all of you i've been waiting
patiently
but it is 122. and um when we're
finished i'll leave the zoom open for
some
informal chats and conversation for
those who have the energy to hang out
um i'll do that for a while too but so
uh
alan i think you were first and then
jamie and then hans if you don't mind
going into session yeah uh i'll be as
quick as i can
um several years ago i actually did a
considerable amount of
boat travel on the um
and made it as far above the proposed
confluence damn at midzone as foreigners
were allowed to go
and then traveled by boat all the way
down by steemer all the way down to
mandalay
uh i checked every fish store fish
market
uh that i could and essentially there
were no um large native river species
for sale in any of the fish markets
and they were hardly any small fishing
boats compared especially to the mekong
anywhere along the erawadi okay that
said
uh burma has four thousand megawatts of
hydropower
of installed capacity some call mostly
hydropower
that's a trivial amount and that's the
main
um disincentive against economic
development
the mute zone projects alone would add
something like
15 to 25 000 megawatts of that to that 4
000
and um you might want to look at the
ebook if you go into
the chat file you'll find a link to my
online ebook on that subject
i love rivers the same as everybody else
here does
but um sometimes it's necessary to get
real with human needs
so pick that up however you see fit but
do look at the chat
link to my ebook on that subject thanks
i i shall do uh just very briefly
i actually uh spent the better part of a
week
in the mandalay fish markets right um
talking to
uh old fish sellers
and trying to figure out you know the
naming of fishes and keeping all of this
straight is an enormous difficult thing
even if you're
working in english or french right let
alone uh burmese which
and the names of all the fish were uh
unfamiliar to me
but it was clear to me that there was
actually a lot of the fish sold in the
mandalay market are
fish that come from uh um
the delta uh and not from the the river
the river itself so i think it's true
that there is not
a sort of huge um fishing industry at
least as i
as i experienced it uh i i think
that um
well the question is whether
the mitzon dam is if if
if you want to make an argument in favor
of hydroelectric power
and it's a plausible argument if you're
concentrating on homo sapiens as i
mentioned earlier
then it behooves us
if i stand in your shoes for the time
being
to figure out how one can generate um
in a cost-effective way as much
hydroelectric power as
possible uh with as little damage to the
natural hydrology
uh of a river and the life forms in the
river
and the mitzon dam i think was not
an optimal solution to that problem
go ahead jamie okay well professor scott
thank you for your wonderful talk i
i this is probably a a big question but
i'll just
put it out there um looking at the uh
rivers prior to our ability to dam up
rivers or reroute rivers of humankind's
ability to kind of alter
the effect do you see that human
settlement
along the erawati responded to these
these transition between this kind of
aquatic terrestrial transition zone that
you
had talked about do you see historically
would we look for the footprint of of
kind of human settlement
in cycles did they understand the cycles
and the changes i i'm thinking about the
red river but i was wondering about the
how
in the erawati if you saw any evidence
of that so when we
actually look for evidence of of human
settlement we should look in this kind
of patterns of
of the of river usage or the river
itself
as opposed to it's a good it's a good
point my under my understanding is that
like
for many other rippers um
that um if you're looking for
early human settlements um you're
looking at and that's true for many of
the delta
towns by the way they happen to be on
little bluffs
right that are above the uh
above the flood plain and relatively
safe from
uh the annual floods and storms uh
and so on um so uh and
and i think that's true for the upper
earwadi as well i'm not
as conversant with the archaeology of
the
early settlements along the irwada as i
might be
um but that's that's my impression that
you don't want to look at the if you
like the
the floodplain the sort of rich uh
floodplain soils but you want to look to
nearby and we're talking about things
like
you know things that are 20 30 meters
uh higher or no more often than um
the surrounding uh the surrounding
floodplain
it's my guess
great and uh hans will have the last
question before we um
stop the recording and then just we'll
have an open few minutes together as
well go ahead hans
thanks hi that was er extremely
inspiring
talk and um my question is about uh
complexity i i found i'm in general
i'm very sympathetic to this uh
opposition
between the the kind of simplification
um
and leaving the the river to to its
complexity
and and that simplification in general
had bad and negative consequences
and little uh kind of prevention
efforts created the possibility for much
bigger floods
but i'm i'm wondering if this is always
true
and whether not sometimes uh
we can also grant rivers the possibility
to to recreate new forms of complexity
or to
adapt to new situations and one
uh reference i had that was was kind of
um the rhine and heidegger because
because actually
in this essay on technology which he
wrote in the 1950s
the rhine plays a crucial role and
specifically the opposition between the
the pre-rectified rhine where poets such
as
holderlin look at the rhine and there's
an authentic kind of
feeling and engagement with the world
and
and then when he in 1950 looks at the
rhine the only thing he sees is
uh dams and hydroelectric dams and he
looks at one
specifically and says this is what
modern technology does to the world it
makes the world
inauthentic unreal kind of so it's like
like you said you know that's
where you cut off all the full legs of
the cat and it's not a river any longer
it's it's something else but but
heidegger's assessment seems to be very
black and white
in the sense that modern technology
totally destroys
everything and there's there's no more
complexity and it's inauthentic
and and my question is whether or not
this is kind of
taking it too far
uh the the question is whether um
heidegger's term inauthentic is the
appropriate one
to use um i mean depending on
the perspective one might want to adopt
and there's several perspectives that
are plausible
um one might say
that the river was
relatively impoverished right
in the sense that its biodiversity was
drastically
reduced right um uh the
if you like the the wetlands that were
if you like the nursery beds
right of most of the life uh along
the rhine were destroyed um
and and i think if if you want to then
like heidegger concentrate on the
the human-produced landscape of dams
right
uh and levees and so on then you get
if you like the inauthentic uh
architectural
interventions of uh homo sapiens and so
i
i see why he wants to call them
inauthentic
i i was impressed um this is something
of a slight diversion
but i was impressed with the japanese um
practice of which was abandoned at some
point but
uh an older practice of river management
uh
in which um japanese river
managers engineers would um
hypothecate a kind of intervention in
the river
for human purposes they were not
interested in the wildlife in particular
um and but they also understood that
they
did not understand the behavior of the
river entirely
and so what they would do is to build a
small
weir where they would uh imagine they
would build a larger weird
and they would build it and then they
would if you like stand back for two or
three years
and see what the river did with it right
how the how it changed the flow
how everything changed right uh around
it whether it
accumulated silt uh what happened down
river and up river from it
uh and so on and then they would in a
sense design their next intervention
which could be the removal of the weir
for that matter they would design their
next intervention by what they had
learned
in the interim by not assuming that they
understood the river
completely at the beginning of the
exercise and i thought
there's a kind of i don't know taoist
humility if you like to
this way of understanding how
to and engineer and landscape a river
that sounds to me
rather more scientifically defensible
given the facts that the hydrology i
mean the
effort to understand the hydrology of
the lower earwadi
um scientifically uh
and the creation of islands in the delta
right
they're just too many variables um to
make it
uh uh a scientific
formula uh and all the more reason
to observe carefully what happens in a
particular instance knowing
that it's not going to be exactly
replicated in the next
instance
i hope that's helpful thank you jim
um i think we should give jim a little
bit of a rest here
um and join me in
uh thanking him for such a fantastic
talk and wonderful conversation
thank you jim thank you